stop new uranium enrichment or we bomb
you which was seemed to seem to be the
the the the last thing and that the the
Bush administration was was putting
forth so no I think that I think that
about the Obama administration wants to
engage Iran wants to talk to them wants
to figure out a way to do that and it
includes Iran's as you mentioned before
the support of what we call terrorist
groups like Hamas and Hezbollah which
you the United States feel is unhelpful
to the peace process the Israeli peace
process israeli-palestinian peace
process but I don't think they figure it
out yet well I don't that mean it's
evident that they haven't figured out
how to deal with Iran or how to approach
this idea of negotiating so there's
little baby steps that we're taking the
United States is taking whether inviting
them to a conference on Afghanistan
which is very an obvious thing do you
know putting out some feelers you know
appointing Dennis Ross not as an envoy
to Iran which wouldn't have made any
sense because an envoy theoretically has
to have someone he can talk to and if
you know something you could talk to why
are you an envoy but for the you know
so-called Gulf as they as the United
States termed it which the Iranians took
offense at because it's the Persian Gulf
nothing golf but there's all these
little steps that we're taking I think
the Obama administration's is is is
aware that this is not an issue that
they have to deal with next week because
Iran is not going to have a nuclear
weapon next week there's a little bit of
time perhaps not as much time as as some
people would like to think there is but
there's time they don't have to rush
into this and they have to be careful
there's a number of ways to look at this
the Iranian elections coming up in three
months does the United States want to
get far into negotiations with Iran or
get very deeply into negotiations with
Iran when there might be a change of
leadership or change of the presidency
does it want to be seen to be
interfering with the Iranian elections
when it's only three months away there's
all these other factors that are
important for for for the Obama
administration to consider and I think
they're just trying to figure all that
out right now
if dennis ross is the man he wants to be
talking to the Iranians the Iranians
will ultimately accept that they won't
like it and I don't think it's
particularly a you know a great signal
for Obama to send to the Iranians or to
even some of the Arab countries of the
surrounding the Persian Gulf because
they're all uncomfortable with dennis
rasso mostly uncomfortable with Dennis
Ross who is viewed by some even within
the American establishment as being far
too pro-israeli and anti Aaron or an
anti even anti-muslim so will their
guard be up yes their guard will be up
with someone like Dennis Ross no
question about that is that an advantage
or disadvantage for their guard to be up
that's a question that I guess President
Obama can answer not not me my personal
feeling is that he is not the best
choice for someone to talk to the
Iranians uranians can be difficult to
deal with if they're not happy with who
they're dealing with and when I say
difficult day and they hold a lot of
advantages right now over us in terms of
you know our own problems not just in
the Middle East all right domestic
problems and economy problems and stuff
like that you know the the military
option for bringing Iran to its knees or
regime change that's kind of over I mean
yes Israel could theoretically go and
bomb the nuclear sites but it's a highly
unlikely event and so Iran feels that
it's it's holds hold some of the cards
here certainly with respect to Iraq and
Afghanistan which are very important to
the United States it does hold cars so
as far as I'm concerned why why choose
someone to be in charge of Iran policy
if in fact that's what his job is
because it's not but it's a little
ambiguous what his job is someone that
the Iranians would not be particularly
forthcoming with or be able to be
comfortably talking to does it make
sense